vous souvenez dans la vidéo sur les
maladies du futur on avait parlé des
nanorobots qui vont combattre les
maladies au coeur de votre organisme et
bien des machines incroyable des
technologies incroyable la médecine en
utilisent déjà et depuis longtemps je
vous propose un petit tour d'horizon des
machines médicales les plus improbables
on commence avec une machine du passé le
poumon d'acier alors tout le monde acier
c'est pas une prothèse métallique
congrès fait aux insuffisants
respiratoires
en réalité c'est un caisson pour aider
les malades atteints de paralysie des
muscles respiratoires à respirer quand
même visuellement on est clairement sur
un appareil sorti tout droit d'un vieux
film de science fiction
sauf que là c'est pour de vrai le
patient s'allonge à l'intérieur avec
seulement la tête qui dépasse le tout
fermé hermétiquement la pression baisse
à l'intérieur du caisson elle passe sous
celle qui règne dans les poumons et sa
force l'air à y entrer ensuite la
pression remonte à l'intérieur du
caisson ce qu'ils chassent l'air hors
des poumons et ainsi de suite
la machine a été mise au point aux états
unis elle a été utilisée pour la
première fois en 1928 à boston et elle a
littéralement arraché une petite fille
de 8 ans des griffes d'une mort
imminente
elle a ensuite principalement été
utilisé dans le cas de paralysie des
muscles causés par la poliomyélite la
fameuse pour lyon même si elle n'a pas
complètement été éradiquée c'est une
maladie qui a pratiquement disparu
et comme dans le même temps les machines
d'assistance respiratoire se sont
modernisés et miniaturisés le poumon
d'acier n'est pratiquement plus utilisé
marthe hammerson qui est décédé en 2009
il ya quand même passé 60 ans de sa vie
alors là même écrire un livre
ok cette fois c'est bien ce que vous
pensez c'est une pièce de rechange pour
les malades du coeur
si on prend ça au sens large il ya
différents modèles qui remplace
différentes fonctions du coeur ça va du
pacemaker qui envoie des impulsions
électriques pour stimuler les muscles
cardiaque au coeur artificiel du total
même si en réalité ne remplace pas le
coeur entier il ya des modèles externes
mais aussi le coeur artificiel
implantable
c'est un dispositif qui remplace les
ventricules qui sont deux des cavités du
coeur et qui est greffé juste sous les
oreillettes mais deux autres cavités
cardiaques
il a pour but de pomper le sang à la
place des ventricules quand ils n'y
arrivent plus tout seul et il est équipé
de batteries externes qui ont une
autonomie d'un peu moins d'une journée
et il faut remplacer l'ensemble du
dispositif au bout de cinq ans alors
c'est court mais c'est mieux qu'un
iphone le coeur artificiel total est
encore en cours d'évaluation mais c'est
pas gagné
on peut aussi citer les appareils qui
permettent au sang de circuler et
d'irriguer les organes pendant une
opération sur le coeur lui même on
appelle ça des machines de circulation
extracorporelle le principe est simple
on aspire le sang avant le coeur on le
fait passer dans une machine où il est
et oxygénée et on l'aurait injecte après
le coeur comme cette chirurgie est un
peu bosser sans que ça bouge
et il n'ya pas que le coeur et les
poumons qu'on leur doublure en métal les
reins aussi peuvent connaître des
défaillances en cas d'insuffisance
rénale qu'elle soit aiguë c'est à dire
que normalement ça va passer ou
chroniques
c'est à dire qu'à priori ça va durer il
faut remplacer une des fonctions vitales
du rhin qui est de filtrer le sang le
nettoyer pour ça on utilise un appareil
de dialyse qui à la fois incroyable et
qui fonctionne de la façon la plus
basique du monde on aspire le sang du
patient on le fait passer dans un filtre
et on leur injecte tout propre ça prend
généralement 4 à 5 heures et il faut
souvent répété l'opération trois fois
par semaine d'autres machines permettent
aussi de nettoyer le sang à l'extérieur
du corps comme les mots filtration qui
ressemble un peu à la dialyse mais aussi
la plasmaphérèse qui permet notamment
traiter des maladies neurologiques ou
fait match nul
bon alors dans un autre registre les
garçons est-ce que vous avez déjà donné
votre sperme
excusez moi vous auriez dû aux gens
merci c'est pour offrir non en réalité
c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça se
passe
donner son sperme c'est la façon de se
masturber la moins glamour du monde on
accueilli de façon très administratif
par une personne qui donne généralement
très plus envie de les acculer ensuite
on est orienté vers une pièce
généralement assez glauque avec un
lavabo et 2,3 revue pour nos douteuses
merci de bien vouloir jouer à cheney là
mais ça c'était avant
avant que les chinois n'invente ce joyau
de technologie médicale le sperme
extracteur l'extracteur de superbes
littéralement c'est une machine qui fait
le boulot à votre place et qui vous
laissent les mains et l'esprit libre
comme quoi le génie parfois c'est juste
adapter une bonne idée qui a déjà fait
ses preuves par ailleurs
salut tout le monde ses propos gaming
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une
vidéo un peu spécial allez retournez
vous penchez vous et tous efforts pour
éviter à votre anus de servir de cobaye
à un médecin inexpérimenté
benjamin locke a mis au point un robot
patients qui permettait s'exercer au
toucher rectal
il s'appelle patrick et il donne ses
impressions en direct qui permet à
l'apprenti spéléo de peaufiner sa
technique en tenant compte de ces
réactions comme ça le jour où il se
retrouve en situation réelle
il a les bons gestes et les bonbons
benjamin locke nos anus vous disent
merci merci benjamin loc
bon donc on a vu qu'il ya des machines
pour remplacer nos organes ou les
stimuler et qui a même des robots
patients pour entraîner les médecins
maintient les médecins justement et si
demain il était aussi remplacés par des
machines
il existe déjà des machines qui
permettent d'opérer à distance en 2001
une équipe située à new york a opéré une
patiente qui se trouvait à strasbourg
grâce à des bras mécaniques reproduisant
les gestes du chirurgien eh ben il
existe aussi des robes aux médecins
n'ont en réalité ce n'est pas vraiment
un robot médecin c'est juste un médecin
dans un robot
ça lui permet de faire des consultations
sans être physiquement présent grâce à
un système de vidéoconférence et de
dispositifs de télésanté connectés et
c'est déjà utilisé dans les hôpitaux aux
états unis mais bon soyons clairs de
manière générale et encore plus quand ça
concerne la santé rien ne remplace
l'humain parce que notre santé c'est pas
juste le bon fonctionnement d'un amas
d'organes qui sont juste là comme sa
côte à côte et surtout parce que la
dimension psychologique est omniprésente
et que ça aucun algorithme et aucune
machine est capable de gérer
efficacement
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là mettez vous bien et surtout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]